let me give you the lowdown on the super
cool features of iOS 17 responding just
got Slicker swipe right on specific
messages and iMessage to reply directly
say goodbye to confusion and hello to
Clarity remember those Nifty photo
stickers well guess what you can now
save them right in your messages keep
the fun flowing autocorrect has leveled
up inline predictive text predicts your
words on the Fly say goodbye to tyos and
hello to a smoother check experience
give your context a personal touch set
custom fonts or fun posters that appear
when your friends call Express yourself
even before you say hello